This video is sponsored by Finnama is in this day and age,
we all know that we should be working smarter, getting our money to work for us.
But if you're anything like me,
that seems like a lot of time and a pretty long time commitment.
So how can we keep up with what's happening in the world of investing or more
basically, where do you start?
If you're completely new to the world of investing? Well,
today's video is sponsored by [inaudible] and they can really help you with
that. Minimize is an app that was designed to,
particularly with young busy people in mind.
The idea is to give you the information and tools you need to invest with
confidence and eventually empower you to become your own financial advisor.
We've been playing around with it for a couple of days.
So let me share with you a few features. So as you'd expect,
they have the financial news packaged in the daily brief.
And here you have the option of text or audio summaries that you could easily
digest on your commute, or while you're walking the dog,
but when you actually want to go even deeper,
but you also have these 100 plus packs.
I know that research was often a stumbling block for me.
It's just so time time-consuming. But with these packs,
you really get a comprehensive outline of top industries or companies that you
may be looking at. Another thing that I liked was the chat function,
where you can ask questions to others in the finance community.
And once you find your feet,
there are Q and a sessions with investing pros and analyst to in a nutshell,
minimize brings the biggest financial news and professional insights to young
investors in language.
People can actually understand that demystifying approach carries over into the
user experience as well.
I found their design really good and uncluttered overall.
It's a great tool providing easy to digest, investing knowledge,
click on the link in the description to set yourself up with a free seven day
trial. So you can see for yourself and remember that you can cancel at any time,
even with the completely free seven day trial.
And if you do want to subscribe all the visual politic viewers will also get a
20% off the premium, yearly subscription.
So check it out [inaudible] and now let's get into it.
Video.
Sometimes miracles really do exist even in the cold hard world of economics.
Look at what happened in Japan after the second world war
For almost 20 years, between 1955 and 1973,
the Japanese economy grew at an annual average of 9%.
And that wasn't all for most of the following two decades from 1973 to 1990
average annual economic growth was over 4%.
It was what became known as the Japanese economic miracle in barely three
decades.
Japan went from being a war torn country to becoming an industrial and financial
powerhouse, largest international creditor.
And one of the richest countries on the planet,
the factories were working on a piece work basis.
The Japanese did not know what it was like to be unemployed and the savings of
families and companies just kept grubbing in the eighties,
Japanese companies where the great technological benchmark it wasn't to see that
their domination over the electronics industry was overwhelming.
The VHS players, the pocket radios, the cameras,
the video game industry,
the Walkman virtually all advances in consumer electronics and almost all the
major fashion companies were located in Japan.
The feeling of prosperity was sub intense that at the time forecasts indicated
that sooner or later the Japanese economy would even outgrow the economy of the
United States. Japan was destined to become the world's largest sector.
But.
As we all know, that never happened. The prediction as so often happens,
simply remained just that the prediction,
the reality was very different in 1990,
a huge economic and financial crisis broke out from which the country,
even today, 30 years later still has not fully recovered,
but what exactly happened?
How did the Japanese miracle give way to decades of economic crisis and
stagnation?
What was it that created one of the biggest bubbles in history to answer these
questions, we have to go all the way back to the 1995.
The Plaza accord.
During the first five years of the 1980s,
the us dollar appreciated by 50% against the Japanese yet the German Mark,
the French Franc and the British pound.
This made us exports more expensive and imports cheaper,
which caused the trade deficit to climb to 3.5% of the us gross domestic price.
[Inaudible].
The result was that for the first time, since the end of world war one,
the United States became a country in debts to the rest of the world. This fact,
together with the difficulty of large American companies to sell their products,
abroad became the main political and economic concern of the time. Now,
what does all this have to do with what happened in Japan?
What is quite simple.
Pressure from the United States led the finance ministers and central bank
governors of the five most industrialized companies in the world at the time.
[inaudible], you know, to States Japan, the United Kingdom, Germany, and France,
to make an agreement at a meeting,
held at the Plaza hotel in New York to intervene in the foreign exchange market
in order to the value of the dollar.
I did look for example, at what happens to the Yen's value against the dollar.
In.
Just a few months, the dollar depreciated by 50% against the yen,
which obviously put a strain on the Japanese export machine after all United
States was by far the Japanese industry's largest customer,
at least 40% of all Japanese exports went to U S consumers.
Well.
Fact is that these laws or agreements were a real turning point.
It was that this point, if there's a huge financial bubble began to develop,
that would wipe prosperity away. Five years later,
pay attention to the two main players in this whole story.
Panic in the Japanese government.
The central bank of Japan behind its doors.
Many of the decisions that led to the great Japanese bubble were made you see
after the Plaza record and the consequent devaluation of the dollar,
the alarm went off amongst the Japanese authorities and the large industrial
groups in the country.
Wouldn't the loss of 50% of the value of the dollar in just a few months,
be a serious problem for the competitiveness of the Japanese industry. Well,
to try to deal with this situation and avoid the risk of crisis,
the government and the central bank of Japan basically decided to do two things
to boost domestic demand that is consumption and to implement an expansive
monetary policy that would try to compensate for the effects of the Plaza
accord. In this way, in the following two years,
interest rates were reduced by 50%.
The government significantly increased public spending and Japanese banks and
coverage by the countries earned.
The authorities began to lend enormous amounts of money to families and
companies so that they could launch themselves into the real estate and capital
markets. Obviously,
this policy caused the prices of real estate assets to start rising steeply,
which in turn increased their value as collateral and therefore the ability of
families and businesses to borrow more and more. And just like that,
the vicious spiral of the real estate bubble had been set up.
[Inaudible].
Don't forget that Japan had been characterized as a country of savers. In fact,
in 1995, it was already the world's largest creditor.
Well with the fall in fixed income yields,
as a result of the new monetary policy,
Japanese savers began to direct more funds to the stock market and the real
estate market, which further fed the bubble.
But these were not the only causes nor the only ones responsible for the huge
Japanese bubble.
There is at least one other key catalyst for understanding how such a
catastrophic balloon was inflated,
a catalyst that has a lot to do with the stock market.
Have you ever heard of Zytech.
Listen up the business of speculation.
Between 1985 and 1989, Japan experienced enormous prosperity.
At least it appeared that way.
The average price of housing increased by more than 300% in that period.
And during these years,
the Nicola stock exchange index tripled its value to reach 39,000 points.
It represented one third of the world's total market capitalization. Well,
the fact is that a financial engineering technique known as Zytech had a lot to
do with this whole process, you see taking advantage of the low interest rates.
The big Japanese conglomerates began to take out large loans to finance the
purchase of shares and real estate.
Something that allowed them to fatten their bottom lines. Why?
Because at the time accounting standards allowed these companies to present
capital gains as income. So the more shares were revalued,
the greater the benefits. In other words,
the more money companies borrowed and the more shares they bought, the higher,
the share price Rose,
which in turn increased the company's profits and the cycle started over with
higher profits. They had more capacity to borrow. And so on. Again.
They can
give you an idea more than half.
Of the companies listed on the Tokyo stock exchange.
We're involved in this system in 1988, 38% of Toyota's profits,
65% of Nissan's profits.
And 63% of Sony's profits were generated by this activity.
And don't think they were isolated cases. No, not at all.
It is estimated that by the end of the 1980s,
between 40 and 50% of the corporate profits of all the major Japanese companies
were generated using this financial technique,
a technique that produced increasingly higher and higher valuations,
All this was happening while many company's core business was not doing
particularly well after the Plaza record and the consequent revaluation of the
yen,
the operating margins of the large Japanese companies that were more oriented
towards exports narrowed considerably that is Japanese companies were
increasingly in debt and their activities were becoming less profitable.
But despite this, their profits were growing and growing. Thanks to [inaudible].
It was an unsustainable situation.
The peak of the bubble.
With which the company share prices were rising and the rapid increase in the
value of the real estate markets cause a widespread feeling of.
Well, it was a surreal world.
Old as if money was dripping from the trees overnight,
the Japanese person who owned a plot of land became rich without doing anything
tagged Murphy banker.
The assets of the Japanese just kept growing at full speed.
These were the years when Japanese tourists camera in hand field,
the luxury stores of the world's major cities, and no wonder in 1990,
it was estimated that the Japanese real estate sector as a whole was worth five
times more than the entire us real estate market.
The estimated value of Japanese golf courses alone was over $500 billion.
There were even some calculations that warned that the sale of an Imperial
palace in downtown Tokyo alone would have been enough to buy all the real estate
in California for its part.
The stock market was also breaking record after record the Nikkei index Rose
from 11,542 points in December,
1984 to almost 39,000 points in December, 1989.
Talking about an annual revaluation of almost 30% that must've been quite a
party.
January 2nd, 1990, the Japanese stock market generates two types of investors.
The believers and the skeptics believers are getting rich.
The skeptics are suffering just when the market seems overvalued.
It doesn't stop rising.
Marcus w broccoli journalists at the wall street journal.
According to data from the international monetary fund in 1989,
Japanese stocks were trading at a P E R at a price earnings ratio of more than
60 while the us and UK stock exchanges were trading at a P E R of 15
and 12 respectively of course, as is always the case.
There was no lack of arguments to support these figures. In this case,
there were three main explanations. Firstly, Japanese economy,
which is closely linked to technology had greater growth potential second,
that the profits of Japanese companies were growing much faster than their peers
in the United States and Europe and firmly that the balance sheets of Japanese
companies concealed significant capital gains and their real estate, of course,
in 1989 with companies quoting PRS above 60,
the justification seemed increasingly difficult to swallow.
[Inaudible].
Fact, in that same year,
the Japanese authorities began to see the writing on the wall.
The company debt kept growing and growing while their competitiveness was
deteriorating at full speed.
Inflation was at risk of skyrocketing and the housing market was already
completely inaccessible to young people faced with such a scenario.
They tried to make a gradual descent, but things had already gone too far.
When the central bank began to slow down the expansionary monetary policy,
everything simple fell apart.
And just like that, the bubble burst in just two years,
the Tokyo stock exchange fell by more than 60% corporate profits plummeted
Zyrtec was operating in reverse. Not only not was it not adding value,
but subtracting it real estate prices also suffered a very hard adjustment and
both banks and large companies face serious liquidity and solvency problems.
Bubble had burst and taken with it.
The entire prosperity of the Japanese economy. Today, 30 years later,
many economic problems derive from this process are still being worked through.
And then the client index sits at around 23,000 points,
40% below the historical peaks. It reached 30 years ago.
[Inaudible].
Short.
This is the story of how Japan experienced one of the wildest financial bubbles
of all time. During the second half of the 1980s.
The question we can now ask is,
do you think we can draw any lessons from this whole experience if your answers
in the comments? So I really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit,
like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that will not mine.
Also the channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll be seeing you in the next video.